B REPUBLICANS INCLUDING OUR NEXT
GUEST ACCUSE SPEAKER PELOSI OF
PRIORITIZING MARIJUANA OVER
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF, AS DEMOCRATS
PUSH A BILL TO LEGALIZE POT
WHILE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
DEVASTATED BY THE PANDEMIC WAIT
FOR A DEAL.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY JOINS US
RIGHT NOW, I BELIEVE FROM OUR
NATION’S CAPITOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, LEADER, FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: IT’S ALL ABOUT PRIORITIES
YOU MAY WANT TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE, YOU KNOW, THEY DON’T HAVE
ANY MONEY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT NANCY PELOSI
WANTS TO WORK ON CANNABIS AND
CATS AS YOU TWEETED.
>> WELL THAT IS SO TRUE, YOU
KNOW, 38 TIMES SINCE THE SUMMER
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE VOTED AGAINST
ANY COVID RELIEF.
WITH ALL THE CHALLENGES AMERICA
HAS RIGHT NOW, WE THINK COVID
RELIEF SHOULD BE ON THE FLOOR,
BUT INSTEAD, THE DEMOCRATS PUT
CATS AND CANNABIS THIS WEEK.
THEY ARE GOING TO OUT LAW BIG
TIGERS, AND THEN THEY ARE GOING
TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS.
THEY’RE PICKING WEED OVER THE
WORKERS.
THEY’RE PICKING MARIJUANA OVER
HELPING THE MUCH-NEEDED MONEY WE
NEED TO GO FORWARD.
THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
CLOSING.
WE LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENING TO
MAX PUBLIC, MAYBE IF THEY WERE
NAMED FRENCH LAUNDRY IT BE OKAY.
STEVE: [LAUGHTER]
>> I DON’T UNDERSTAND THE
DOUBLE STANDARDS OF WHAT WE
SEE FROM THESE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
S.
HOW MANY TIMES DID SPEAKER
PELOSI TELL US WE WOULD NOT
LEAVE CONGRESS UNTIL WE GOT SOME
COVID RELIEF BILL.
THAT WAS MONTHS AGO.
THERE IS A DISCHARGE PETITION ON
THE FLOOR THAT DEMOCRATS CAN
SIGN THAT THEY SAID THEY WOULD
AND THEY HAVEN’T THAT WOULD
BRING MONEY TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS WORKERS.
THERE IS A NUMBER OF TIMES, BUT
NOW THEY SCHEDULE THE FLOOR AND
THEY PUT CATS AND CANNABIS BUT
NOT COVID.
AINSLEY: IT’S JUST UNBELIEVABLE
HOW DO THEY NOT HAVE A HEART FOR
THESE PEOPLE THAT CAN’T PAY
THEIR BILLS RIGHT NOW AND PEOPLE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
WHERE DO YOU STAND WHEN IT COMES
TO THE STIMULUS PACKAGE BECAUSE
I KNOW PELOSI AND SCHUMER ARE
SAYING 908 BILLION, THAT
BIPARTISAN DEAL AND MCCONNELL
AND MNUCHIN 500 BILLION, WHAT DO
YOU SAY?
>> I STAND WITH MITCH MCCONNELL
AND MNUCHIN BECAUSE THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE’RE DOING HERE.
IT’S EVEN MORE.
THERE’S 138 BILLION THAT’S
ALREADY APPROPRIATED THAT IS
SITTING THERE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
WORKERS, BUT PELOSI WON’T LET
THAT GO FORWARD.
THERE’S MORE THAN 100 BILLION
THAT’S ALREADY BEEN APPROPRIATED
THAT WOULD GO TO STATES THAT
HELP THEM WITH THEIR SCHOOLS AND
THE UNEMPLOYMENT AND OTHERS.
WE CAN DO THIS IN A SYSTEMATIC
WAY TO HELP THOSE WHO NEED IT
WITHOUT ADDING MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE THE
MONEY THE DEMOCRATS WON’T
ALLOW IT TO BE SPENT.
BRIAN:  YEAH, I HOPE IT’S A
BIPARTISAN SITUATION, SHE CAME
DOWN OFF 2.4, DOWN TO 1.8 AND
NOW SHE’LL TAKE 900 BILLION
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WORK
ING ON IT KEVIN I HOPE YOU
GUYS GET SOMETHING DONE THIS
WEEK BECAUSE THEY OBVIOUSLY
FEEL THE PRESSURE TO MOVE AND
YOU’RE ABOUT TO GET EVEN MORE
POWER BECAUSE THE MAJORITY RIGHT
NOW, THE MAJORITY WHEN YOU START
IN JANUARY, IT COULD BE FROM YOU
TOLD ME THE NUMBERS 222 TO 213
SO THEY ARE GOING TO BE DEMOCRAT
S ALREADY DEFLECTING
FROM THEM AND SHE’S GOING TO
NEED REPUBLICANS TO PASS
ANYTHING, SO MAYBE YOU GUYS CAN
GET TOGETHER AND LAY THE GROUND
WORK FOR SOMETHING BIPARTISAN
BUT SOMETHING ELSE IS GOING ON
IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
YOUR TWO-FACED POLITICIANS ARE
TELLING THE PEOPLE TO DO ONE
THING AND THEY ARE DOING THE
EXACT OTHER.
HERE IS BILL MCGLUAN, FROM KTTV
OVER IN CALIFORNIA.
HE BROKE THIS STORY.
>> I WAS TIPPED OFF ABOUT THIS
BY SEVERAL PEOPLE IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY WHO WERE
LESS THAN PLEASED BECAUSE THEY
SAY THIS IS YET ANOTHER GLARING
EXAMPLE OF HYPOCRISY FROM OUR
LOCAL POLITICIANS, SO WE’VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET AN INTERVIEW WITH
SUPERVISOR ALL DAY LONG TODAY,
AND THEY’VE BEEN TELLING US, HER
CAMPUS HAS BEEN TELLING US SHE’S
TOO BUSY IN MEETINGS ALL DAY
LONG.
IT TURNS OUT THAT’S NOT TRUE
BECAUSE SHE JUST HAD AN
INTERVIEW WITH ANOTHER
AFFILIATE IN LA WHERE SHE IS
PLAYING THE VICTIM AND
ESSENTIALLY SAID SHE’S GETTING
DEATH THREATS AND SHE CAME HERE
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO PERSONALLY
DELIVER THE NEWS TO THE
RESTAURANT THAT SHE WAS GOING TO
PUT THEM OUT OF BUSINESS.
STRANGE EXPLANATION.
BRIAN:  SHE’S TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE GOING TO OUTDOOR DINING
AND THEN GO DO OUTDOOR DINING
LIKE YOUR.
>> GOVERNOR: AFTER FOND YOUR
MAYOR.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO YOUR
STATE HAVING --
STEVE: DOUBLE STANDARD.
BRIAN:  IT IS.
>> THESE DOUBLE STANDARDS ARE
DESPICABLE.
IF EVERY RESTAURANT IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD JUST CHANGE
THEIR NAME TO THE FRENCH LAUNDRY
I GUESS IT BE OKAY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THEM, THE MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO, SHE WAS AT THE FRENCH
LAUNDRY.
THE GOVERNOR, HE’S AT THE FRENCH
LAUNDRY WITH NO MASKS SITTING
NEXT TO THE MEDICAL LOBBYISTS.
IT’S OKAY IF YOU’RE ONE OF THESE
ELITE DEMOCRATS THAT DICTATE
WHAT YOU CAN DO IN YOUR LIFE,
BUT NOT WITHIN THEIR OWN, THEY
CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT OR
MAYBE THE MAYOR OF AUSTIN THAT
FILMS THAT YOU SHOULD NOT WHILE
SITTING IN CANCUN.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES AMERICA SO
MAD.
THESE ARE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
THAT THINK THEY ARE ABOVE
EVERYONE ELSE AND CAN TELL US
WHAT TO DO, BUT AGAIN, THEY
COULD DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
AND IN THESE SOCIALIST COUNTRIES
, THESE ELITISTS AND
WHAT DO THE WORKERS NEED?
WHAT ABOUT THOSE CHILDREN WHO
CAN’T BE IN SCHOOL THAT WE CAN
HAVE RESOURCES TO PROTECT THEM,
TO HELP THOSE WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED
, TO HELP THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES?
I WAS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
I KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE TO HAVE A
DREAM, BUT TO HAVE GOVERNMENT
CRUSH YOU IN EVERY ASPECT?
THAT’S JUST DESPICABLE.
STEVE: AND YOU LEFT OUT SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI WHO WHEN THE SALONS
WERE CLOSED SHE WENT IN, SHE GOT
HER HAIR DONE, NO MASK, AND THEN
SHE BLAMED THE SALON OWNER,
SALON OWNER SET ME UP, I DIDN’T
DO ANYTHING WRONG.
ALL RIGHT, LEADER MCCARTHY THANK